adults are now for their Recreation
going to bouncy castles I saw this story
in the Wall Street Journal Wall Street
Journal is not a sensationalist tabloid
paper far from it the new Night Out
adults-only bouncy houses grown-ups try
to rekindle a childhood Pastime this
time with Achy muscles that hurt my back
my back adults are discovering that
jumping in bouncy houses a childhood
Pastime is not the same when you're
older and less Nimble grown-ups aren't
just hopping with their kids but are
increasingly bouncing around with other
full-grown humans adults are renting
bouncy houses for weddings birthdays and
Company parties some are having as much
fun as youngsters